[Music]
and I warned you news submitted by I
would to actor Adam driver walked out of
an NPR interview after they played a
clip of him singing he's get he's got a
phobia of it right is that real what's
his phobia of him seeing his
performances yes like no serious where
like he won't sit through any of the
actual screenings when he does goes to
premieres and stuff he'll sit in the
green room or like for the Star Wars one
he had to sit there and he was like I
get why that movie sucked ass what about
like uh washing back takes onset to see
if he got the informative playback
he probably just goes whatever the
director says I just test problem Johnny
Depp's like that - Wow he doesn't
watches Johnny Depp won't even look
himself in the mirror you won't you
never see himself he's on the clock that
was a [ __ ] vampire yeah you're saying
that he felt totally cold and as though
he was about to be sick when he had to
sit through the premiere of Star Wars
The Force awakens yeah me too I was at
the premiere as well same for him
actually I was there because I was so
excited about the new Star Wars you what
a [ __ ] joke
did you slide in the green room is like
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] move because I hated
it
I saw JJ Abrams as close to me as TIFF
is right now and I was like this not
even kidding I swear guy than that I
cannot believe you that happen I can't
believe whatever I mean it could it
could not I swear I swear on my life
yeah kylo Ren so weird
wimpy is [ __ ] little Jedi ever saw yeah
I liked him in girls I thought it was
really maybe that's why he doesn't want
to see himself [ __ ] huh
he's supposed to be some crazy I thought
which stars did I watch when he came out
he's supposed to be like this crazy boss
and then and his voice was dope and when
he took his mask off I'm like he's like
I miss my dad yeah
my dad that's all well didn't you kill
him yeah yeah and then a little oh yeah
misses him but then he doesn't miss them
in like a menacing way like a little
[ __ ] this is embarrassing
why what's embarrassing I'm not a madman
I smash more all the time
you don't talk about bar all the time
all the costumes and share their go on
stage their giant dick sometimes I
thought I'm the only one who cares here
because you guys anything out there
before something what he's sensitive the
only person who cares cuz I listen what
yeah you don't even know that I talk
about war on here sorry here's some like
really feminine tones over here like it
was hurting my screeching yeah why am I
so important no I'm not important Juarez
that's I'm trying to say no you're
saying nobody listens to you like you
have some important [ __ ] to say all the
time and that we should be listening to
that I think that you should listen to I
know is that what you're saying yeah
Jean should I say I have an important
thing to say first would that help
no just I don't think you should assume
that you're more important than anyone
else in this group no but I don't we all
equally contribute no but I remember to
say but we're even like a little bit
above I listen to all the things that
you guys say that's [ __ ] I do
we're done we come to this conversation
he says guarda so he's doubling down no
the audience knows I talk about guar
they're gonna have my beckons video I'm
excited they're gonna go search for
their to try to find the video that you
tell ya know which there's a way to
audio sir they listen to me I understand
they listen to me command a command with
a formula I wanna see if I remember I
see thank you anyway
we're talking about Adam driver here so
he was doing this interview with NPR and
this is not the first time you've done
an interview with NPR for their fresh
air
talk show he's done it before in the
past and in the past they had given him
a warning like oh you know you could
take off your head cuz they don't do it
in person these interviews it's like
what the interview or is in a different
studio and then the interview he's in a
different place so they're not in the
same room so they had warned him in the
past like oh you can remove your
headphones when we're about to play
these audio clips of you acting or
whatever cuz they know about his phobia
yeah so then he did do that in the past
but then for this interview they also
gave him that same warning and he just
he got up and left like he just hated it
cuz he started playing this scene where
he's singing in marriage story and so I
have that clip it's a big thing that I
got to see what made him bail Oh what
the [ __ ]
fail such a weird-looking dude yeah bail
too
[Music]
somebody crowd me with mouths somebody
forced me to kill somebody make me come
through I'll always be there as
frightened as you to help us survive
Bing
in this be great singer comes in for
that my old master back in 1999 monica
lewinsky also transition I guess it
looks up more walked out mid interview
for the same show and she was singing no
no they held up her blue dress somebody
went like I was talking this personally
and they're kind of like I was like man
she's like no so what happened was that
the questions were too intimate and that
she didn't want to continue the
interview because she was supposed to
she was under the impression that the
conversation was supposed to be limited
to subjects such as her book tour and
recent 'equal was for the [ __ ] water
the president actually in 1997 like
that's your fame so they were saying
though like the interviewer was saying
that she wasn't hostile and that she
even apologized for having to end their
interview but in the end she did end it
and so when this whole atom dry
everything came out she tweeted her
support for him all shut up saying
subject self care is always a choice Oh
suck it nice gym no okay like it's not
necessarily that atom drivers like diva
and you know people look at that way the
other way is like well he's just trying
to mental health yeah I get that like I
don't really like certain videos that
I've been in and like if you were to
play that I'd probably be like I cringe
best and then leave yeah especially if
they weren't like your people has warned
them like hey please don't do that or
whatever
yes take a [ __ ] you that's really rude I
do think it's weird that he didn't like
just oh boy if they gave him the heads
up though they didn't know but like I'm
totally in support of him like you know
taking care of himself
I just think it's weird of like I knew
that they were gonna be like hey and
here's the part we're gonna play the
song yeah maybe he was just thinking
about his own self and her own
performance like not even [ __ ] you to
them but like yeah oh [ __ ] I hate myself
and I wanted just that wasn't if
somebody were to play the old sketches
that I did with my ex-girlfriend to me I
would consider it an assault that's
that's valid we weren't even dating I
was like why is he in days I've ever
felt to like I'm Lilly imprisoned I have
to do this what are those sketches
looking IVA did are they there
they're online sure no the body normally
online I'm honest man I didn't judge it
until you would cancel other things that
like we were all supposed to write a
movie together and like he would cancel
cuz he had to go film this sketch series
and I was like he's canceling for that
yes pretty important and you cancel
multiple times for that she conveniently
scheduled it or on the same time no I
don't think it was like that it was just
one of those things like we have to do
right now like man sex life sucks
basically we have to do this thing about
yeah life this that's gonna be fun that
was her pitch
that was the the way I thought that she
was saying that okay cool that's your
recollection yeah that stuff to me I get
this Adam driver [ __ ] and I'm like dude
you play that [ __ ] to me how do you
fight slobbers only I might note this we
slap is there part of the palm that
you're like no daddy come jab ease don't
the perimeter of the gentleman slap yeah
Thank You Nikki with the gloves
[Laughter]
did you wait and it succeeded okay but
he was very gentlemanly about he's very
polite and he wished me well okay